we got windows Isaac's first time seeing
the house now that it's up and directed
because last time you saw it was just
the land right yeah
did you see the concrete in person you
saw the concrete you saw the foundation
process it looks cool and now there's
two floors how does it feel to feel like
walk through the house no and kind of
like really feel like this this is our
house feels good yeah like man I can't
wait until the future he makes you
excited for more money
[Music]
it's so cute could they did was walking
through a wall here think it's like
we're ghosts
you threw all your superpowers
[Music]
yeah you walked in he was like oh it's
not like the model home I'm like dude
we've been playing in Minecraft like
this cuz the model home is flip like
it's exactly like in Minecraft how we
built it can't wait to decorate this
place I wish I had this lighting though
no ceiling yeah it's great glass ceiling
that ambiance it oh yeah let's we
created a little door do you have a
permanent marker on you we can write our
names like inside of the house
[Music]
how does it feel to see everything like
step by step every week we come here
it's like a different version of the
house oh I do cool they're building or
toilets and stuff our future poops gonna
go through there I don't know every time
I come here I'm just like this is not
fast enough
hurry up hurry up hurry up I want more
progress like every time I come I'm bill
I'm a little let down actually by how
little it has been done yeah a lot has
been done in such a short amount of time
but it just feels like it's not enough
we're too excited I know we are I can't
wait to start seeing like the flooring
you're like walls it's like Oh what is
it a sheet rock that we're like the
fluffy stuff what does that cost
insulation insulation the window we see
I think does it keep out the sound you
think pink is here let's try it
how's the sound house is open we don't
get a lot of light in this house no
we're about so right now it's like 3:30
ish so it is past high noon but this is
like our living room and our bedroom
be kinda dark because obviously we
couldn't have foreseen this when we
bought the lot but the light tends to
stay behind our home so ilex room the
garage and the garage of all places and
then uh the other the other bedroom
those are the rooms that are gonna get
the most light but it's okay we'll be
cool all right we have our house that's
fine
true but I am kind of bump because that
was like the one main like major major
thing for me was natural light I just
let it flood in with natural light he
imagined Washington baby in here too
your babies are gonna be washed here uh
or maybe the big tub actually how
they're tough coming alone oh it's empty
I can see through all yep
dangerous in here at least our bathrooms
gonna have good lighting
here sort of watch the walls are gonna
cover it the order whatever comes
through the window at least right like
the windows like tinted don't want to
take photos of our neighborhood and then
yeah I have photos like that my parents
do at least does it feel like yours yet
still doesn't because technically it
isn't do you haven't actually the down
payment really and you don't have to pay
a mortgage that's and I'll feel like
really you don't have an attachment yet
to this place the nine but not an ounce
of attachment because I do have like
every time I come here I already feel
like like when there's cars parked out
front I'm like oh wait parked in front
of my house I feel it but like very very
very slightly like it's not like oh this
is my house like I don't feel that at
all it just feels like oh this is cool
they're building this building that's
awesome
we're gonna live here eventually that's
awesome like it doesn't feel like this
is my house I try to picture this house
with walls and like with our things and
in and I'm like cool like her bed frame
will be there and like
or furniture stuff so just like creating
the future home in my head but because
that isn't but now I don't have that
attachment because I think oh that's
that house that's true that's true yeah
he excited me your neighbors
good neighbors at least I feel good
about the one set of neighbors that we
met which I think are those guys next to
us mm-hmm
they were really cool we first met like
I you could just already sense like the
energy it's like oh I'm gonna get a lot
of you there have been like very very
few people in my life that I've met
where I'm like you're a hard person to
get along with so I really think that
our neighbors are gonna be really
awesome and they're gonna be awesome to
get along with so yeah I'm not too
worried about that
and we're protected under the HOA Clause
worried about you might be the neighbor
people don't like now that we're gonna
buy a house that makes me feel really
different about this home compared to
how I feel about all the rental
properties you've ever been in so I
don't know why that is like worried is
that you're kind of like a porcupine now
it's like everyone stay away this is 9
but then for me it's like oh cool now
we're all in the same club guys the fact
that it's a brand new neighborhood - I
think that's like it's kind of like
we're all here together guys versus like
oh you're the new guy or whatever oh
yeah that's not true that doesn't that
won't be relevant here
[Music]
we have walls now the plaster on the
outside is done I just got a paint it
next thing we gotta get big cabinets
electrical is pretty much done and a lot
of Lana has changed since it's like it's
been three weeks since we last came a
lot has changed is this deteriorate the
quality of the house of the training the
rains get into the walls according to
their timeline the builders timeline
give it about another month or so should
be moving in here
[Music]
huh
[Music]
that's why they're working on that house
right now
oh sweet we got a Bannister now
[Music]
and still did it
it looks really easy when you just hire
a handy guy are you doing okay so it why
they painted the walls are ready yeah
these are the color girls I look at this
our sinks sinks space here they move
fast now that's true that's good
actually right after all the experience
building all the other ones
so this should be like a seasoned build
in a baby room in the office I mean and
the Isaacs room gets the most light this
is dope how much like you gets in here
[Music]
you take the master bedroom
[Music]